so
sixth possible feature of neurolink and
pcis
was mentioned a few times by the team
under the flag of telepathic
communication or telepathy
conceptual and consensual telepathy
so i think in general to
enrich the the bandwidth
in quantity and quality of the
communication between two human beings
so you can imagine being able to
communicate
not just through this kind of uh 1d
realm of words but to communicate visual
concepts first of all
but also kind of mind maps of like
multi-dimensional concept maps that are
in our mind when we're trying to
reason through things to be able to
communicate
those in some way it doesn't even have
to be kind of uh perfect replication
but any kind of improvement
increase in the bandwidth of the
communication between humans
on the visual or on the conceptual side
is super interesting
i think somebody on the team mentioned
kind of art to be able to
communicate creative artistic kind of
things in your mind and
share them with others without having to
learn the skill of
converting that art into uh something in
the physical world that's
uh that can be you know observed by
others
you can sort of directly without
learning the skill be able to
communicate all the crazy beautiful
things that are in your mind
i think for my world of like programming
for example
it'd be exciting to think that two human
beings
at any level could sort of collaborate
together uh
it gives a whole other meaning to pear
coding where two people can
collaborate together as they work on a
project of any kind whether it's in the
programming world or any kind of design
world
architecture any kind of illustrations
all that kind of stuff collaborations
between humans
for uh intellectual labor for
design for engineering work or any any
kind of collaboration
in the intellectual space and finally i
think it would be pretty good for
podcasting
so uh for those of us who don't like the
sound of our voice
and uh funny enough don't like to be in
front of the camera
instead of having to convert my thoughts
awkwardly in a monotone voice
into a microphone i can somehow
communicate them in a much richer way
which
i think at least for an introvert i
think the kind of things going on in my
mind
seem to be much more eloquent and
interesting
than the kind of things that come out of
my mouth when i perform the conversion
so from like a car mechanic or maybe i
should say
like brain mechanic perspective my
uh converter is not working very well
between the
the brain thoughts and visualizations
and concepts based to
mouth speaking different uh
english concepts so i look forward to uh
this podcast
being consumed and generated
telepathically
you